>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING, AND
WELCOME TO "TUCKER CARLSON
TONIGHT."
JUST ABOUT 24 HOURS AGO, THE
PRESIDENT ISSUED A SWEEPING
DECLASSIFICATION ORDER.
HE GAVE US ATTORNEY GENERAL
WILLIAM BARR BROAD AUTHORITY
TO FIND AND RELEASE ANY
DOCUMENTS RELATED TO
DOMESTIC SURVEILLANCE,
SPYING BY AMERICAN
INTELLIGENCE AGENCIES OVER
THE 2016 CAMPAIGN.
YOU THINK EVERYONE WOULD
LIKE THIS.
IT WOULD QUALIFY AS DONALD
TRUMP'S LEAST CONTROVERSIAL
DECISION SINCE PRESIDENT.
EVERYONE IN WASHINGTON SAYS
WE LOVE TRANSPARENCY.
DEMOCRACY DIES IN DARKNESS
"THE WASHINGTON POST"
REMINDS US EVERY MODERN.
>> EVEN NOW MEMBERS OF
CONGRESS ARE CALLING FOR THE
IMPEACHMENT OF THE PRESIDENT
BECAUSE PORTIONS OF THE
MUELLER REPORT WERE
REDACTED.
LET'S SEE EVERYTHING,
THEY'RE TELLING US.
OKAY.
LET'S DO THAT THE PRESIDENT
SUDDENLY APPEARS TO AGREE
WITH THEM.
LET'S SEE EVERYTHING.
SO HOW DID THE LEFT REACT
WHEN HE SUGGESTED THAT?
NOT WELL.
WATCH THIS.
>> IN THE END, THIS IS ALL
PART OF A PATTERN OF
POLITICIZING OUR JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT INSTEAD OF
ALLOWING JUSTICE TO BE DONE.
>> I KNOW IT SOUNDS LIKE THE
ONION.
IT'S TRUE IT MAY ALSO BRING
A TEAR TO YOUR EYE.
>> TO QUOTE A FORMER HIGH
LEVEL DOJ OFFICIAL, THIS IS
A GROTESQUE ABUSE OF THE
INTELLIGENCE COMMUNITY.
>> THIS IS AN ATTEMPT BY THE
PRESIDENT TO LET THE WOMEN
AND MEN OF THE INTELLIGENCE
COMMUNITY KNOW, FBI AGENTS
AND OTHERS KNOW THAT IF YOU
INVESTIGATE HIM, HE'S GOING
TO COME AFTER YOU.
>> RIGHT.
>> THAT BILL BARR AND OTHERS
ARE GOING TO COME AFTER.
>> YOU THERE IS AN
INVESTIGATION OF THE SAME
MATERIAL JUST DESIGNED TO
FURTHER THE PROPAGANDA
AGAINST THE MUELLER
INVESTIGATION POLITICIZING
THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT
THAT'S WHAT THEY'RE
CONCERNED ABOUT.
POLITICIZING THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT DIDN'T SEEM TO BE
A MAIN CONCERN WHEN FBI
AGENTS SPIED ON AND THEN
SLANDERED CARTER PAGE AN
ENTIRELY INNOCENT AMERICAN
CITIZEN.
WHEN ANOTHER TWO FBI AGENTS
WERE CAUGHT TALKING ABOUT AN
INSURANCE POLICY AGAINST
TRUMP BECOMING PRESIDENT,
AND THEN PROMISING TO STOP
HIM, THAT WASN'T
POLITICIZING THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT EITHER ACCORDING
TO THEM.
NEITHER WAS THE FIRED HEAD
OF THE FBI SLEEKING TO THE
POLITICAL LAW PROFESSOR TO
MAKE A POLITICAL CASE.
NONE OF THAT WAS
POLITICIZING THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT.
BUT AN ATTORNEY GENERAL
DECLASSIFYING DOCUMENTS THAT
ALREADY EXIST THAT HE HAD
NOTHING TO DO WITH CREATING
NOW HE HAS GONE TOO FAR.
CNN TROTTED OUT SERIAL LIAR
JIM CLAP TORE LET VIEWERS
KNOW REALLY THIS COULD BE
DANGEROUS.
>> CONCERNING BECAUSE THERE
HAS ALREADY BEEN SO MUCH
INFORMATION DECLASSIFIED
ALREADY THAT PARTICULARLY IN
THE FORM OF THE MUELLER
REPORT AND THE PREVIOUS
INDICTMENTS GOING BACK TO
OUR ORIGINAL INTELLIGENCE
COMMITTEE ASSESSMENT WE DID
IN JANUARY OF '17.
I WONDER WHAT ELSE IS GOING
TO BE DECLASSIFIED THAT THAT
RISK JEOPARDIZING SOURCES
AND METHODS.
>> Tucker: PRECISELY.
IS HE CONCERNED THAT THE
FBI'S METHODS MIGHT BECOME
PUBLIC AND THAT'S EXACTLY
WHAT WE NEED TO KNOW A LOT
MORE ABOUT THE FBI'S
METHODS.
THE FBI HAS A LOT MORE
POWER.
IT CAN LEGALLY BREAK DOWN
YOUR FRONT DOOR AND SHOOT
YOU.
ITS INVESTIGATIONS CAN
DESTROY YOUR LIFE EVEN IF
YOU ARE INNOCENT.
IT'S HAPPENED TO A LOT OF
PEOPLE RECENTLY.
SO THE FBI ABSOLUTELY MUST
BE ABOVE SUSPICION IF YOU
CARED ABOUT PRESERVING OUR
DEMOCRACY WHICH THEY CLAIM
THEY DO YOU WOULD
IMMEDIATELY DISINFECT THE
FBI WITH SUNLIGHT.
JAMES CLAPPER HAS NO
INTEREST IN DOING THAT
NEITHER DOES THE REST OF
OFFICIAL WASHINGTON.
THE ONLY PRINCIPLE THEY CARE
ABOUT IS SELF-PRESERVATION
AND THEY WILL SAY ANYTHING
IN ITS SERVICE.
CONGRESSMAN ADAM SCHIFF OF
CALIFORNIA RESPONDED TO THE
DECLASSIFICATION ORDER THIS
WAY, QUOTE:  WHILE TRUMP
STONEWALLS THE PUBLIC FROM
LEARNING THE TRUTH ABOUT HIS
OBSTRUCTION OF JUSTICE,
TRUMP AND BARR CONSPIRE TO
WEAPONIZE LAW ENFORCEMENT
AND CLASSIFIED INFORMATION
AGAINST THEIR POLITICAL
ENEMIES.
THE COVERUP HAS ENTERED A
NEW AND DANGEROUS PHASE.
THIS IS UNAMERICAN.
END QUOTE.
GOT THAT?
DECLASSIFYING INFORMATION IS
NOW A COVER-UP.
IT'S UNAMERICAN.
KEEP IN MIND THIS GUY IS THE
CHAIRMAN OF THE HOUSE
INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE.
ADAM SCHIFF IS A COMPLETE
NUT CASE.
HIS ALLIES IN THE MEDIA
THOUGH ARE CERTAINLY MORE
SUBTLE THAN THAT.
THEY KNOW THAT COVERUP ISN'T
A PLAUSIBLE WAY TO DESCRIBE
DECLASSIFICATION.
IT'S LAUGHABLE.
SO INSTEAD THEY ARE GOING
WITH THE TERM DISTRACTION.
WATCH.
>> DISTRACT AND DEFLECT.
>> IT'S VERY GOOD
DISTRACTION.
>> DISTRACT FROM A DAY OF
VERY BAD NEWS.
>> AN EFFORT TO DISTRACT.
>> DISTRACT.
AS USUAL, YOU ARE WATCHING
PROJECTION AT WORK.
A DISTRACTION, YES.
WE ARE FAMILIAR WITH THAT
CONCEPT.
FOR TWO AND A HALF YEARS WE
LISTENED TO THEIR ABSURD
THEORIES ABOUT RUSSIAN
COLLUSION.
THE GOAL WAS TO DISTRACT US
FROM THE IMPLICATIONS OF THE
2016 ELECTION.
AND MORE BROADLY TO KEEP
AMERICANS FROM NOTICING WHAT
IS HAPPENING TO THEIR
COUNTRY.
THE DYING SMALL TOWNS, THE
NEEDLES AND GARBAGE FLOODING
THE BIG CITIES, THE OVERRUN
BORDER, THE MIDDLE EASTERN
WARS THAT PERSIST FOR NO
REASON.
THE GROTESQUE AND GROWING
INCOME INEQUALITY ON THE
COAST.
THE RISE OF CHINA ABROAD, ET
CETERA.
THESE ARE ACTUAL PROBLEMS.
SOME CASES THEY ARE FULL
BLOWN CRISES.
THEY NEED SOLUTIONS AND
SERIOUS PEOPLE TO THINK
ABOUT THOSE SOLUTIONS EVERY
DAY THIS FARCE ABOUT RUSSIA
AND COVERUPS CONTINUES IS
ANOTHER DAY THAT AMERICA
GETS WEAKER AND MORE
DIVIDED.